I mean it it's like Shakespearean right
you went to the inauguration and that
was because you were first lady not
because you've been on the knee right
and and you know I really tried to get
out of going you know because I was
going not as the candidate or the
opponent but as a former first lady
because the tradition is presidents and
former first ladies all show up
regardless a Republican or Democrat to
show support continuity of our
government so you know we we thought
okay maybe others aren't going so you
know we we called called the bushes and
the elder bushes were in the hospital
which I think was legitimate
[Applause]
younger questions and they said yeah
we're going we called the Carters they
said yeah we're going so you know bill
and I looked at each other and said well
we got to go oh my gosh I just I try to
describe in the book what that felt like
because I didn't know what to expect
what I wanted to have happen was despite
the kind of campaign he ran I wanted him
to rise the occasion of being our
president and being the president for
everybody not just people who supported
him that didn't happen
and so we were we were sitting there and
we were listening I was sitting next to
George W Bush and Bill was on my other
side and we were listening this really
dark divisive speech that I describe as
a cry from the white nationalist gut and
I was so disappointed really so so sad
that it wasn't an outreach it was a
narrowing and a hammering of what he had
said before and it's reported so I put
it in the book it's reported that George
W Bush at as it ends says that was some
weird [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]